okay so the topic of this video is going
to be proteins and then a little bit
later amino acids and enzymes let's get
started
so what does this phrase you are what
you eat mean to you if we're in class
we're going to talk about this but let's
move forward
so when it comes to proteins they are
one of the four categories of organic
molecules the other being lipids and
carbohydrates and nucleic
acids now proteins are used in a variety
of cellular functions for example dna
replication one piece of dna can copy
itself into two pieces of dna this
requires proteins along the journey
facilitated diffusion is another example
of a cell function requiring proteins
here's a picture of our cell membrane
here comes a glucose molecule and
through the protein channel labeled
glucose can be brought into the cell to
be used as needed
you know when it comes to photosynthesis
and creating glucose you know here's a
leaf
they take in water and carbon dioxide
and sunlight and will create glucose and
oxygen none of these are proteins but
proteins are used along the way
same in cellular respiration the process
of making atp here's a mitochondria the
mitochondria will take in glucose and
take in oxygen and through cellular
respiration creates atp and water and
carbon dioxide none of these are
proteins but proteins are used along the
way
so let's talk about the basic building
block of a protein or a monomer of a
protein that's called an amino acid
here's an amino acid they have weird
names that leucine
leucine for example might bond with this
other amino acid called valine and they
bond through what's called a peptide
bond and then here's another amino acid
alanine bonded together here's a uh and
altogether there's actually 20 different
amino acids that exist here's another
one that's bonded to the chain and
another and another and another
and ultimately you have this chain of
amino acids
which goes by the name of a polypeptide
now polypeptides are not quite proteins
but they're created by the ribosome
so here's a ribosome what the ribosome
does is it gathers amino acids maybe it
gathers glycine and then bonds it with
leucine and then bonds it with lysine
and bonds it with another amino acid and
then another amino acid and then another
amino acid so notice we have two
polypeptides here one in orange and one
in green
well what happens next is proteins are
formed from a collection of polypeptides
and so these two polypeptides will
intertwine with one another and twist
and fold and wrap into what's called a
protein
now the exact arrangement of amino acids
is what determines the protein so in
this case the orange and the green will
intertwine and when they react they form
this normal proper shaped protein right
here
well here's the other here's another of
the orange chain and here's another of
the green chain let's pretend there was
a mistake in making the green one
that amino acid at the back
is mutated now when these
two chains intertwine and twist and fold
and wrap because there's a wrong amino
acid the shape of the protein will be
altered and therefore its function
and a disorder very well could occur
sickle cell disease is a great example
of a disorder that can result if
proteins are not built properly if you
don't have sickle cell disease and your
red blood cells are normal they're round
and they roll freely and they travel
through your veins and arteries but if
you do have sickle cell disease like you
see in the picture your red blood cells
tend to look like this and this causes
them to clog and they don't carry oxygen
well this is caused by a misshapen
protein by one wrong amino acid in the
polypeptide chain
okay so let's go over amino acids in a
little more detail again what's an amino
acid it's the monomer the building block
of a protein there are 20 different
amino acids that exist for instance
alanine and valine and lysine and
methionine now they all have little
different qualities to them
for example these are nonpolar and
hydrophobic in green these are polar
hydrophilic and have a neutral ph in
blue these have a basic ph in pink these
have an acidic ph these qualities will
be important in a little bit
well if we talk about their structure
they have five basic parts now because
these are organic molecules they're
going to be built around carbon attached
to the carbon will be what's called an
amino group a nitrogen and two hydrogens
is what we call an amino group
and then there's a single hydrogen
attached to the carbon in the middle
and then there's what's called a
carboxyl
a a carbon uh a carbon and a couple
oxygens then a hydrogen so you can see
what they did uh whoever named this they
took the word carbon and oxygen and kind
of just mushed them together and let's
call that a carboxyl
and then there's what's called the r
group now this is interesting
because when you look on the periodic
table and you try to find the uh the
the element with an r
it doesn't exist so what is this r group
well i said earlier there's uh there's
20 different amino acids well here's
three of them serine glycine alanine i
don't have space to draw all 20 of them
and notice they all have a central
carbon
they all have the amino group they all
have that single hydrogen
they all have that carboxyl group so
they're virtually identical so far they
are identical how do they differ for one
another
they each have a different r group
serine's r group or side group is this
right here
alanine's r group or sorry glycine
glycine's r group or it's the earth's
side group is this right here and
alanine's r group or side group is this
right here so the the r group isn't an
element on the periodic table it's just
the rest of the amino acid each of the
20 amino acids has a different r group
so here are three generically drawn
amino acids notice how there's just the
r group on them
well my question is
how would these three amino acids how
would they even bond with one another to
make a polypeptide you might know of the
chemical process called dehydration
synthesis and so i've highlighted the
ohs and h's in red and so let's look on
the two left amino acids they're brought
together and with the help of something
called enzymes
see how there's a h there's two h's and
an o can you think of a molecule that
has two hs and an o h2o water and in a
dehydration synthesis
the h2os are removed and notice what
happened is a peptide bond formed
bonding the two amino acids together
let's do that again on the right hand
side
notice how there's two h's and an o
and then enzymes will play a role
something called enzymes will play a
role and
water is removed and then another
peptide bond forms so notice how these
three amino acids have now been bonded
into one larger polypeptide water was
removed hence the reason why it's called
a dehydration reaction
so here's a little review challenge for
you pause the video i'm gonna go over
the answers now for number one i hope
you said amino acids number two
twenty number three
carboxyl number four
r group or side group number five
amino group number six
ribosome number seven
peptide bond number eight
r group or side group let's continue on
so when it comes to digesting proteins
proteins are common to foods such as
meats like steaks and chicken and fish
also common to beans and eggs and nuts
while the proteins are swallowed they go
into your stomach the food is swallowed
it goes into your stomach and the
proteins are then denatured which means
they're broken down so here's a protein
that you just swallowed and it's
in your stomach and the stomach acids
and enzymes in your stomach begin to
break down
the protein into for instance
polypeptides
and then the polypeptides will enter the
beginning of your small intestine called
the duodenum
and once they enter the beginning of
your small intestines uh chemicals from
your gallbladder and chemicals from your
pancreas will break them uh the
polypeptides into their individual amino
acids and so now that the amino acids
have been
released they can enter your bloodstream
and your heart will transport them
through your circulatory system all
around your body
well if we look at
the chemical process that breaks down
for instance a
polypeptide this is called a hydrolysis
reaction
so again there's the peptide bond in a
hydrolysis hydro implies water
in this case enzymes along with water
are going to be used to break down
one amino acid from the others let's do
that again here comes another water
molecule and this peptide bond will be
broken
and notice how that polypeptide has now
been broken into three amino acids this
is what's called a hydrolysis reaction
let's talk about how proteins take their
shape how they fold
first of all the final folded shape of a
protein is crucial to its function
if the shape of the protein is irregular
the protein will not perform its
function as needed and a disorder could
happen
and so there's actually four stages of
protein folding
the primary structure of a protein it's
just a chain of amino acids linked
together by the ribosome into what's
called a polypeptide and there you have
the primary structure
the secondary structure hydrogen bonds
well between the amino groups and the
carboxyl groups will cause
the polypeptide to fold like you see
right here this is called the secondary
structure
tertiary which just means third the
tertiary structure remember each of
these amino acids has a different r
group and the r groups will interact
with one another because some of them
are hydrophobic and hydrophilic some of
them are acid some are bases
and they twist and fold and compress
even further
again they do this because the r groups
have different characteristics this is
that the characteristics i discussed
earlier in the video
and then finally the final shape of the
protein the quaternary structure
many times proteins are made from not
just one
polypeptide chain multiple polypeptides
chains will be twisted and folded
together to make this final protein
notice this protein was made from three
different polypeptides
and so if you look at computer created
models of proteins they often look like
this
notice how there are different colors
representing different chains of
polypeptides
so let's talk a little bit about enzymes
first of all enzymes are a category of
proteins so they're made from
folded chains of polypeptides
now in general all enzymes will lower
the energy needed to start a chemical
reaction
enzymes are sensitive to their
environment
meaning they can be denatured and broken
down if there's a fluctuation
or a change to their natural environment
normally for example our body
temperature is around 98.6 degrees
fahrenheit and if so
our protein might look like you see in
the picture
but let's say we have a high fever of
let's say 104 degrees maybe even higher
that few degree elevation can cause
various proteins and enzymes to denature
and break apart and this is why a high
fever can actually have serious
sometimes even fatal effects on the body
so if you have a high fever enzymes are
losing their ability to work which can
stop
a variety of cell functions which again
as i say stated could could actually be
fatal
another is alcohol poisoning can lower
the ph in our bloodstream and that can
denature the proteins that are floating
around suspended in the bloodstream
enzymes are very specific in their
actions here's a vein with red blood
cells rolling through them let's pretend
you have a meal you have a hamburger you
have some corn and you have some french
fries now are there actually hamburgers
and corn and french fries traveling
through your veins of course not but the
molecules from your food are broken down
and those molecules are broken down by
your enzymes
so for example there's an enzyme called
amylase amylase is an enzyme that will
break down the starch that's in your
food
and so here is a molecule of starch
notice it's made from many bonded
glucose molecules
so amylase is an enzyme
that will break down this one single
starch molecule into
many individual glucoses
and then
and then it's those glucoses that are
absorbed into your bloodstream and will
transport through our blood to all the
cells in your body but where did those
glucoses come from they came from your
hamburger and they came from the corn
that you eat and they came from the the
french fries that you had
one thing to mention enzymes are
reusable so
here we have some amylase enzymes that
have just broken down a starch molecule
well those same amylases can be used to
break down another starch and those same
amylases can be used to break down yet
another one
so there you have it a quick overview of
proteins i hope you found this video
helpful try this little practice quiz
thanks for watching